donc je vous emmène dans le fond d'urzy
suivez-moi
entre chaque rayon se trouvent des
milliers de souvenirs anciens véritable
trésor de la mémoire montargoise le
fonds local de la médiathèque n'a pas
vocation à s'ouvrir au grand public
pourtant la collection est
impressionnante livres journaux dessin
tout ce qui parle ou a été fait à
montargis et ses environs se trouve ici
si le fonds s'est constitué grâce à des
legs la médiathèque reste à l'affût pour
acquérir de nouvelles pièces ce qui est
sûr c'est que on ne laisse rien passer
on ne laisse rien passer ces attaques
des convois quelque chose qui il ya une
occurrence montargis amis heavy
demandeurs chalet de la porte l'agglo on
l'achète mais bon il ya toujours des
choses qu'on découvre et puis souvent
les gens des sociétés savantes les gens
qui nous connaissent
aya un tel ouvrage qui parle de est donc
là on a aussi des gens qui se servent de
dépisteurs si toutes les pièces de la
collection n'ont pas de valeur marchande
elles présentent toutes un intérêt on y
retrouve par exemple tous les numéros
existants de la république du centre ou
bien des ouvrages du 19e ou xviiie
siècle et parfois des trésors encore
plus inestimable
c'est un livre a en fait religieux
c'est le livre a été offert en 1884 sur
54 pardon à la ville de montargis donc
c'est un livre magnifique avec des
lettres illustrées
comme vous pouvez le constater enfin si
vous souhaitez consulter ses ouvrages
il suffit d'en faire la demande à la
médiathèque mais vous ne pourrez pas les
emporter